era enero de 2016 la oposición
venezolana vía recién ganado la mayoría
en la asamblea nacional el congreso
después de haber estado dominada por
mayoría oficialista- chavista por más de
15 años estábamos en la redacción del
periódico y mi jefa paula quinteros en
una reunión editorial nos dice al grupo
necesitamos un periodista para cubrir la
fuente parlamentaria yo respondo casi
inmediatamente casi sin pensarlo quiero
hacer esa periodista a pesar del miedo a
que ella intuía supondría salir de mi
pequeña burbuja del este de caracas
paula me contesta de forma inquisidor a
pero mínimo tienes que estar dos años en
el cargo reafirmo con certeza aceptó y
asumí el reto
el primer día fue aterrador
atravesar la ciudad el tráfico de la
ciudad en una mototaxi un servicio de
taxi pero en motos de baja gama que se
ha puesto muy de moda en venezuela
debido a la escasez de gasolina y al
tráfico quienes viven ahí lo conocen
llegar a las proximidades de la asamblea
nacional y encontrarme con grupos
chavistas que te gritan que te insultan
que están visiblemente armados se
respira atención e intimidación y a
pesar del miedo se dibuja ese día como
uno de los más importantes de mi vida
profesional de mi vida dentro me siento
como pez en el agua pero fuera de esas
paredes de esas rejas la realidad que me
aterra sigue allí
pasó un año y como pasa en todo uno se
acostumbra hasta que a finales de enero
de 2017 comenzaron a gestarse las
protestas opositoras antigubernamentales
que duraron más de seis meses no había
pasado el período de dos años indicados
por mi jefa tengo que cumplir con mi
palabra una mañana como todas las las
plan de 100 test mañanas de caracas
llegan a la redacción 40 chalecos
antibalas y 40 máscaras antigás
me entregan mi kit
fue un momento de perplejidad para todos
y quiero salir corriendo
esa sensación no se me quito ni uno solo
de los más de 180 días que estuve
trabajando las manifestaciones el día
más aterrador llega cuando me equivoco
en una cobertura y le indicó a mi
motorizado jose que se meta por una
calle por la que no había que meterse
había un edificio que estaba tomado por
grupos paramilitares que intentan
retenerlos por suerte eso sí yo logramos
esquivar los pero shakira mi compañera
de cobertura y fotógrafa y su compañero
motorizado quedan retenidos
inmediatamente ajos y yo decidimos
regresar para intentar negociar que los
suelten no hay tiempo para explicaciones
comienzan los disparos y yo solo veo el
destello de las municiones a los lados y
escucho jose repetirme una y otra vez
señorita su explotó eso es plomo y yo le
contestaba jose sácame de aquí sácame de
aquí
nos vaciaron un alma entera en los pies
al poco tiempo shakira y su compañero
también lograron salir ilesos de esa
intimidación pero ese día decidido que
ya no quiero seguir arriesgando me había
atravesado por lo menos cinco ocasiones
en los últimos dos años en los que me
había enfrentado en las que me había
enfrentado a armas de fuego las dos que
llevo más presentes en 2016 el 23 de
octubre grupos chavistas entraron de
forma violenta y armada también a la
asamblea nacional amenazando a todos los
que estábamos allí a mí se me paró al
lado un hombre con unos lentes unas
gafas oscuras encapuchados y tenía una
pistola en la mano ese día se convirtió
históricamente en el segundo asalto a la
asamblea nacional venezolana una semana
más tarde entraron en la redacción dos
hombres también con pistolas
y nos amenazaron a todos de que si no
hacíamos lo que nos decían nos iban a
matar nos encerraron en la sala de
reuniones pero por suerte ese episodio
no pasó a mayores porque uno de mis
compañeros logró tuitear que estábamos
secuestrados la prensa reaccionó a estos
dos episodios se le sumaba mi carga
emocional de que emitió en el año 2015
había sido asesinado en su casa por unos
menores de edad que entraron a robar no
fue político
no era político era artista pintor
escultor
pero ese día el de la calle equivocada
el miedo me gano y el siguiente paso era
claro tenía que volver a empezar o más
bien tenía que terminar poner un punto y
final para poder volver a empezar todo
pasa en cuestión de dos semanas me
despido de mi familia y me mudo para
españa'
en ese momento también works hubo
incertidumbres pero es cuando me doy
cuenta de la importancia de la red de
conocidos mi antigua profesora de
flamenco me recibe en el aeropuerto y
vivo con ella unos días en parla o
munícipe a las afueras de madrid me
quedaba un poquito lejos pero también me
reencuentro con unos amigos de un máster
que hice y una de mis amigas me ofrece
una solución temporal para vivir era
mucho más cerca del trabajo fue en ese
momento cuando sentí que por fin
comenzaba a construir una vida en la que
los ladrillos los lleva poniendo yo
comencé de cero pero no mi jefa que ya
la que me había advertido lo de los dos
años en la asamblea me ubica en la
redacción de su periódico español
como se escribe en español en españa
como se titula como se hace fuentes
también las cosas pequeñas cambian se
llenan las 10 y se escribe en pretérito
perfecto compuesto
volví a comenzar
el resto afuera se me hizo se me hace
todavía grande pero hay dos cosas que me
dan seguridad
la primera es ese enjambre de personas
que se me han ido atravesando en el
camino en el camino que y que lo han ido
marcando y que están en la agenda ya sea
por una entrevista una cobertura una
amistad o alguna actividad académica y
la segunda es entender la vulnerabilidad
del ser humano y de la vida
federico garcía lorca decía en una
conferencia en la que hablaba de la
ciudad de granada que para entender a
esa pequeña ciudad había necesidad de
empobrecernos un poquito y olvidar
nuestro nombre
un día que confieso me encontraba un
poco frustrada por tantos cambios o
quizás simplemente extrañado a mi casa
me informan de que el equipo del
periódico en venezuela había ganado el
premio de la sociedad interamericana de
prensa por la mejor cobertura noticiosa
justamente por la cobertura de las
protestas del 2017
lo comento en la redacción
pero siento que se alegran pero no
entendían mucho porque yo le daba tanta
importancia y quizás no sabían lo que no
sabían era lo que había detrás de ese
premio el llanto de la madre de juan
pabló pernalete al llegar al ambulatorio
que olía a bomba lacrimógena ya vinagre
y encontrar el cuerpo de su hijo que
había sido asesinado con un disparo a
quemarropa de una bomba lacrimógena en
el corazón juan pabló tenía 20 años
o como los compañeros de la sinfónica de
la orquesta sinfónica nacional
despidieron a su amigo y violinista
armando cañizales con un concierto
tras haber sido asesinado también por
las fuerzas de seguridad del estado una
semana más tarde con una letra de metal
tenía 17 años ese día en la redacción de
madrid
recordé una mañana que amanecí con los
ojos hinchados llenos de ampollas y con
poca visibilidad el médico dijo que era
emocional cuando no quería seguir viendo
aquel horror
y un poco sola entrada del premio
recordé a lorca olvidar nuestro nombre
y es así como cada día vuelvo a empezar
en españa tengo mucha suerte la vida
mejoro mejoró muchísimo pero el año
pasado mi papá se enferma le da un
cáncer que dura tres meses en llevárselo
y tengo que volver a venezuela a ese
lugar del que prácticamente me sacaron a
tiros del que salí aterrada
fui y volví
se me ha quitado el miedo sí y no cada
mañana amanezco con un sustito en el
corazón el estómago hasta que mi mamá
que está en caracas escribe y se reporta
en el grupo de la familia buenos días
mis amores y es así como cada día
de alguna manera vuelvo a empezar
aferrándome a mis seres queridos a mis
conocidos y a ese pequeño jardín
interior
y cada día trabajo como si fuese trabajo
para el mejor y para el peor escenario
me levanto y reporto venezuela el mundo
el mundo a venezuela doy clases de
fitness bailó flamenco y ahora exploro
el mundo de la publicidad para los
medios de comunicación en españa
creo en lo que creía paco de lucia
profundamente creo en eso en las mil
horas de trabajo y hablando de paco
pienso en otra gran flamenca en sara
baras en una anécdota que contó por un
espectáculo que presentó en parís y
decía que a los franceses a los
parisinos les gustaba mucho el flamenco
ella decía no al espectáculo el flamenco
mientras tú de más en más riesgo estés
más les gusta
yo me quedé con él soy y siempre ahora
imagínese fantaseó que si existe algún
dios nos observa con una mirada un poco
cómplice desde arriba viendo cómo nos
enfrentamos cada día a nuestros riesgos
a nuestros retos porque es que creo que
se trata de eso de que el riesgo es
parte de la vida gracias
[Música]
i